This episode was made possible by generous
supporters on Patreon.
Hey Crazies.
We’ve been doing a lot with space-time diagrams
lately.
Figuring out how different observers measure
the passage of time.
But that got several of you asking:
Does that mean the future is predetermined and we don’t have freewill?
Well, maybe, maybe not.
Deep questions like this require careful scrutiny.
All we know for sure from diagrams like this
is that time exists.
That doesn’t necessarily mean that the future
or even the past exist.
Hmm.
Maybe we should define these words first.
The past is the time, or period of time, before
the present.
The future is the time, or period of time,
following the present.
So both of these are defined in terms of the
current moment.
That kind of makes sense.
The present, the “now” is what we’re
experiencing.
But it feels like the past exists.
We remember the past happening.
Well, none of us remember that.
Or that.
But I certainly remember all of these moments,
whether I want to or not.
But does that exist? or is that just a
memory we're experiencing now?
The future also feels like it’s going to
happen
even if we don’t know what it’ll be.
Does that exist? or is it just a prediction we're making now?
Hmm.
Let’s see what this looks like on a space-time
diagram.
You are here.
This event represents your present. Your now.
Whether you’re stationary, moving at a steady
speed, constantly accelerating,
or doing something completely random,
you can’t go any faster than light.
Light travels along these diagonal paths,
so your path is stuck inside those lines.
This half happened before your present.
It’s your past.
All the events that might have influenced
you.
This half will happen after your present.
It’s your future.
All the events you might influence.
Your entire life is contained inside these
regions,
no matter what you might have done or what
you might decide to do.
Those two regions are called your past and
future light-cones.
Cones? How are those cones?
Oh, right right right. Let me explain.
Only having a single space axis makes these
look like triangles,
but if you include a second space axis, you
can see they’re really cones.
You just have to consider light traveling
in any direction.
Actually, there are three space axes.
Yeah yeah, but our axis limit is three
and one of them has to be time.
Besides, most motion happens in two dimensions
anyway.
Let’s not over-complicate this.
Anyway, this still leaves some things open.
I said the word "might" a lot during that
space-time diagram.
So are we predetermined to travel our space-time
paths or not?
This comes down to an idea called causality
or "cause and effect."
And relativity rule number 6 says it must
be maintained, no matter what.
That means, if one event causes another, then
everyone agrees they happen in that order.
Cause before effect.
Let’s say you are the cause and you want
to affect me at particular time.
I must be somewhere in your future light-cone.
Maybe I’m directly on the path you’re
taking, so you’ll be able to touch me.
Maybe I’m not on your path, but I’m close
enough to throw a rock at.
Maybe I’m so far away from you, the only
way you can affect me is with light.
In all cases, from all points of view, the
cause comes before the effect.
So is all of time just a string of cause and
effect?
Eh, not so fast.
If an event happens outside your influence,
the distinction between past and future kind
of melts away.
Say there’s an event outside your future
light-cone, outside your influence.
You might still think it happens in the future
because, on your timeline, it happens at a
later time.
But someone else might say it happened in
the past
because, on their timeline, it happened at
an earlier time.
Wait wait, something can happen in one person’s
future, but another person’s past?
Yep.
So the future and the past are very personal
concepts.
They belong to an observer.
But an observer is only in the present, which
reminds of something.
There’s one property of the universe we
haven’t considered: Locality.
or in local-ity.
We’ve discussed this in previous videos,
but it could bear some repeating.
Whether we’re talking basic mechanics, electromagnetism, space-time curvature,
or even quantum fields; the universe is inherently local.
The idea is that a physical thing can only
be influenced by its immediate surroundings.
In other words,
in order for a thing over there to affect
me here, it has to either come here
or send something here.
Which brings us to another relevant question:
How big is here?
It’s really small.
Local for a person might look like this.
This is pretty small for me.
OK, I have to admit, this is a little uncomfortable.
Anyway, this is my space, my here.
And it works for anything the size of me.
If that local box is too small, like it would be for my space station,
then it’s a little overkill, but it’s fine.
If it’s way too big, like it would be for
particles,
then it simply won’t work.
So smaller is better.
Ideally, it would have exactly zero size,
but that poses a few problems.
The main problem being that we can’t divide
by zero.
It just doesn’t work.
Luckily, we’ve got a trick that gets us
around this problem.
Let’s start with two points separated by
this much space.
Say this point is at 5 and this point is at
6, or 5 plus 1,
because they’re separated by one unit.
Maybe it’s inches, maybe it’s centimeters.
Whatever. It doesn’t matter.
If we make the space a little smaller, maybe the second point might be at 5 plus one half,
or 5 plus one tenth, or 5 plus one hundredth,
or 5 plus one thousandth.
The points keep getting closer together.
They’re almost the same point, but not quite.
We can keep this up, we can get closer
and closer
and closer.
Until the points are at 5 and 5 plus an unimaginably
tiny number.
So tiny, it’s not even useful to label it
as a number anymore.
We call it an infinitesimal and label it dx.
Welcome to calculus!
I know my calculus.
You plus me equals us.
Anyway, an infinitesimal is an amount of space
that is as close to zero as we can get
without actually being zero.
It’s as local as our math can get.
Of course, dx is just one dimension.
dx and dy make two dimensions.
Include a dz and you’ve got three dimensions,
also known as space.
Include a dt and you’ve got a four-dimensional
space-time.
The volume dx dy dz is the local here and
the dt is the local now.
That’s all that really exists.
There is no universal reference frame because
there is no universe
at least in the way that people usually understand
it.
This space-time diagram is only a map of predictions
about a non-existent future.
and predictions about a non-existent past.
It’s attached to you as you move through
space-time.
Space-time doesn’t deny you freewill because
the future doesn’t exist.
All that exists for anyone is their local
here and their local now.
You might not have control over much in your
life.
But you always have a choice about what kind
of person you are here and now.
Make that choice a good one.
Please share your thoughts in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like
to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
Why is the speed of light that specific number?
Well, we know it can’t go at infinite speed,
because that would violate causality.
It has to be finite.
But the exact value is kind of an accident, as far as we can tell.
It could just as easily be a different value
in a different universe.
That universe just might not have humans in
it.
Anyway, thanks for watching!
Fast Fast!